please welcome Eliza Skinner everyone
alike so I live in LA but I was just in
New York for a few months for work Wow
it's fun being in New York boy do they
hate LA and they will tell you about it
and it's weird because this is my home
but they will say things that people
would never say about your home no one
would ever walk in your house and be
like oh I could never live here but
people just seem fake but I love it here
it's where all my friends live my
ex-boyfriends I had lunch with my
ex-boyfriend the other day thank you for
leaving me alone emotionally on that one
thank you thanks I'll take care of
myself um I had lunch with my
ex-boyfriend and I know that a lot of
people when you see your ex you like to
like dress up for it right so you can be
like like look what you're missing you
made on the stay
I like to go in the opposite direction
just look at shitty as possible so I can
be like yeah you stuck it in this trash
bag you proud of yourself I win the
break-up it's all about winning and
loosing in the game of love my most
recent ex is actually my ex-fiance so oh
you came with me that time thank you
thank you no he's fine I'm fine I just
don't know how to stay in love with
someone after watching them sleep on an
airplane okay if you're not laughing at
that that's cuz you sleep on airplanes
the rest of us want a poor in your
mouth and sew it shut you look like a
big dead baby it's hard to feel sexual
about you after seeing you that way it
was actually hard for me to start dating
again after that cuz uh I mean I would
go out in a couple dates with a guy and
be like funny story I used to be engaged
and then there would just be a
man-shaped hole in the door I think they
were making a lot of assumptions about
me a lot of unfair assumptions I think
they were assuming that I was like oh
please it almost happened I came so
close
kasumi do I still have the dress
I keep it in my kitchen and sometimes I
dance with it do you want to dance with
my dad not true I keep it under my bed
so I can smell it to sleep no I didn't
do any of that stuff like as soon as
soon as the ring went on I was like ah
it feels like fire how I expected
now I blame these guys though it's not
them it's me I'm bad at dating I don't
like dating love is great dating is the
worst like you have to get to know
people so fast some stranger have those
getting to know you questions
at one questions just gonna unravel your
whole personality one question I had a
guy in a date ask okay
do you like cats or dogs and I was like
what to draw are you serious are we six
you're asking me my favorite animal and
you're giving me two choices like I
can't like both I can like both cats and
dogs clearly by the way that I've
answered the answers cats
I think the only reason ask that
question is to rule out all the people
who are like cats or dogs uh neither I
like birds have you ever noticed that
they have knives for noses and their
eyes look like marbles pushed into tiny
buttholes I said that - a friend of mine
and he was like oh yeah bird people are
so weird I knew this girl she had like a
buttload of birds I was like that
doesn't sound like that many birds like
it depends a lot on the person and the
birds I'm like what they're willing to
put up with it I feel like for me it's
maybe one bird but honestly I don't I
haven't checked I don't know